as the most recent mass shootings in
Nashville and Louisville prom protest
and public mourning the NRA is holding
its annual convention some Republicans
with an eye on 2024 are using the
Gathering to shore up support with the
organization's members while at the same
time responding to calls for stricter
gun laws CBS News Chief election and
campaign correspondent Robert Costa
spoke with some of the presidential
hopefuls NRA members and protesters at
the convention in Indianapolis
good morning the Republican presidential
race has taken a brief detour from those
early voting states of Iowa and New
Hampshire and come here to Indiana for
the National Rifle association's annual
Gathering many republican contenders
yesterday made their pitch to the
attendees but the debate continues to
rage Nationwide on gun rights is there
anybody in the room who doesn't own a
gun please raise raise your hand if you
have the courage former president Trump
rallied the NRA crowd Friday but let's
be very clear the issue there's not too
many guns the issue is too many Thugs
hoodlums and Savage criminals on our
street instead of getting these
dangerous Killers into jail
we have radical DA's but he wasn't the
only one with other possible 2024 rivals
on stage two including former vice
president Mike Pence big media big
government even big business have locked
arms to advance a pernicious radical
left agenda trampling on free enterprise
the freedom of speech the freedom of
religion
and the right to keep and bear arms for
pants a former Indiana Governor it was
home turf and while they avoided making
a joint appearance it was still the
first time he and Trump have shared a
stage since they left office former NRA
president David Keane told CBS news that
Trump is popular here but the race is
fluid well before we get to the actual
nomination stage I think the NRA is
always up for grabs off stage some of
the other 2024 figures made their way
through the Halls greeting activists and
talking with reporters it's been
interesting to hear a lot of the
speeches today and the focus that each
of the speakers has had you know the
people in this audience want to hear
from people that will continue to fight
for them and their second amendment
rights
while this Gathering is known for having
14 acres of guns and gear it is also a
focal point in the nation's intensifying
debate over guns and violence following
recent mass shootings in Louisville and
Nashville we're doing something wrong in
this country we need to do something
about these guns some Indiana teachers
this week pleaded with State lawmakers
to bolster gun laws there's nothing more
chilling than talking to your
five-year-old who's in kindergarten and
hearing them talk about how they have to
hide in a dark bathroom so bad guys
don't hear them inside the convention
hall attendees were unswayed I don't
think it's necessarily a gun problem
it's a it's a mental health problem is
what it is and the debate over gun
rights will shift now to Nashville
Tennessee where the Republican National
Committee is meeting today and having a
fundraising event all is the debate in
Tennessee continues over gun rights
following the expulsion of two black
Democratic lawmakers who had been
protesting in the wake of the Nashville
shooting for CBS Saturday morning Robert
Costa Indianapolis